großer festakt in der hecken asturien
kaserne in wien meidling
grund dafür ist eine neue vereinfachte
kommandostruktur im österreichischen
bundesheer zusammen zusammengeführt zu
dem kommando streitkräftebasis wird
unter anderem die heeres logistik
zentren das informations
kommunikationstechnologie und cyber
sicherheitszentrum sowie alle militär
medizinischen einrichtungen
das neu aufgestellte kommando ist damit
der zentrale logistik dienstleister des
bundesheers insgesamt umfasst das
kommando streitkräftebasis 4000 personen
mit soldaten aller dienstgrade
zivilbedienstete und lehrlinge in 22
dienst stellen und dies lokationen in
allen bundesländern von dieser kommando
zusammenführung erwartet sich
verteidigungsminister kunasek eine
wesentliche steigerung der effizienz ich
glaube etwas was sich jeder von ihnen
nicht nur wünscht sondern etwas was auch
notwendig ist um in zukunft effizient
die aufträge kunasek nützte die
gelegenheit noch einmal um mit klaren
worten dem extremismus im bundesheer
eine klare absage zu erteilen im
österreichischen bundesheer ist kein
platz für extremismus ganz gleich von
welcher seite er kommt und alle von
verteidigungsminister abwärts über alle
kommandanten natürlich auch die
zuständigen ämter sind angehalten und
angewiesen genauestens hinzuschauen und
gegebenenfalls sofort einzuschreiten